monsieur la police nationale soit un
signalement d'un homme grand costaud 1
mètre 90 qui serai dans les parages
oui on est assez fade regarder un petit
peu émissions vont connaître une petite
imitation away avec plaisir et néo pâtes
ont apporté au revoir à dire que c'est
on va je ne sais pas [ __ ] c'est quoi
ça moi j'ai pas testé ce matin c'est
bien qu'ils soient sont la pluie et
montrent leur voiture ils sont là les
extras ps qui sont là il faut pas rester
là il faut pas rester là je vous dis je
n'étais pas là on vous dépose un peu
plus loin monsieur aux habitudes il fixe
comme nous mais je suis pas fou mais
moins fermé le séjour au congo
monsieur décliner votre identité
attention si je doute qu'on t'a fait
qu'un mois après les trucs ou pas est-ce
que tu as pris les traits julien bru
bombe installée en plus comme vous j'ai
comme moi je vais mourir les gens
vraiment sentiment chez vous monsieur
c'est voter une à enlever raconté
doucement ou commentateurs chien vous
arrêter vous arrêtez pas d'insultés ça
comment vous allez venir mais rata
gauche conduit merde
[Musique]
après le japon de voitures savez je le
savais regard des compteurs ils sont
lents regardent ils ont bien sûr sont
bons arrêts mais les royals et où ils
ont tendance à cacher mais si la crise
mais si c'est dans le noir de paris qui
viennent souvent
on va y aller mais là on va se calmer
c'est gérer oui j'arrive en forme et
aptes à temps mais non je veux leur
parler
[Applaudissements]